>>My name is Dylan.
I'm thirteen years old
and I'm an eighth grader
at Gilbert H. Hood Middle School.
When I was really young my
mom set me up on the computer
with this huge ball mouse,
with the most gigantic button
in the front of it.
And I used educational
tools on the computer
to help me learn my
phonics and my alphabet.
I'm not sure if I would know my
alphabet if I didn't have technology.
>>At seven fifteen, I go to the
high school for my math class.
>>I'm just not gonna talk
about Michelle Obama's fashion.
>>At about eight, I go to
my regular middle school
for the rest of my classes.
>>Kimberly: You have three
choices on how you would
like to represent your
reflections in your website coding.
And Dylan's gonna be actually
picking his technology piece today.
>>Dylan chose to just make a podcast
so that he could voice record himself
into Garage Band, export
it as an iTunes file
and then he embedded
it into his web page.
>>Dylan: I've grown to see
that the experience I have
in middle school are much different
than the ones I've had
in elementary school.
>>Peter: In the fall of
2007, Dylan approached me,
asking if I'd be a coach for
him for his ThinkQuest project.
I had never heard of ThinkQuest
before, but when I read
about it, I was fascinated.
It's a global contest
where students form a team
and create a website that's supposed
to be both informative and fun
or entertaining for
children, to raise awareness
of whatever issue they
decide to focus on.
Through his other projects,
he had already made connections
with other students around the world
that he wanted to be
part of this team
and he knew exactly
what he wanted to do.
>>Dylan: The project we were working
on was called Sentenced for Life
and we were working on a website,
trying to get more people aware
about animal cruelty and how it
could be possible to stop it.
We used online forums
and chats and conferences
to communicate with each other.
I collaborated with other
children from Argentina,
Japan and India to
work on this project.
>>Peter: It's funny, because
I'm a child of the fifties.
I remember having projects
in my class where two
or three students said,
"We can't work on this
at home 'cause we live a
mile away from each other."
And in Dylan's project, they
were collaborating continually.
And again, it blows me
away that students all
over the world can have
these daily discussions.
>>Dylan: I think it's pretty amazing
to be able to have a conversation
with people from other countries
that easily, but honestly,
since I've been doing it for a
really long time, I've gotten used
to that being able to happen.
[Dylan playing piano]
>>Krithika: He writes
songs, he composes music,
he makes ring tones, downloads them.
He makdes videos, publishes
them, you know, on YouTube,
he has karates on somedays.
>>Dyland: Three, two, one, go.
>>Krithika: He walks around with
friends, carrying his flip camera.
They take random video clips.
>>Boy 1: Hey, you guys.
Eat frozen H2O.
>>Dylan: Oh, I wish
I was still filming.
>>Krithika: When they go out
to shoot it, they have no idea,
but when they come back
they would spend twenty,
thirty minutes putting it together
and sometimes it's just hilarious.
>>Ha, ha, you fell for it.
>>Krithika: They come
up with something
which is really interesting.
I think it's made him a very creative
person using all these technologies.
>>Kristin: Dylan and two other
students have come together.
They're three very close friends
and they sort of live by the motto
that going green isn't a
choice, it's a responsibility.
He started a website, GreenYourLives
.org, and that sort of holds all
of the information that his
team is working on currently.
>>Dylan: The Go Green initative,
I'm working with a few teachers.
We're making movies and flyers to put
up to help get the school
district to start going green.
And we actually now
have all seven schools
in the school district doing that.
>>When I talk to people the
communication takes place
through this chat box here.
I like to use WebX because it
allows me to show what's going
on on my computer screen to someone
that could be extremely far away.
That ripple effect was a transition.
And I'm showing video to the other
people that are in the meeting
to get them to help review.
>>Okay, guys, guys, join.
>>For fun, I go online and I play
video games where you can collaborate
with other people in a
completely different location.
>>Peter: When I was in school,
the expression was "Think globally
and act locally," you know, 'cause
that was basically the only option.
>>Dylan: Hello, I invited
you to a game.
>>Peter: But I look at
Dylan and realize that no,
these kids can think
globally and act globally too.
>>All right, we got
it, Okay, let's go.
>>Dylan: Yesterday's film
is very, very simple;
Two of my friends started throwing
snowballs at two of my other friends.
>>All right, ready?
Three, two, one.
>>Boy 1: Hey, you guys,
eat frozen H2O.
>>Boy 2: Ha, ha, you fell for it.
>>Dylan: We usually come up
with better plots than that.
>>Okay, that's good.
>>Hey, that was horrible.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org